et le chef de la diplomatie russe a mis
en garde contre le scénario cauchemar de
la confrontation militaire fente
citation saga lavrov qui accusent l'otan
de rapprocher son infrastructure
militaire des frontières russes la
correspondance à moscou devant la goffe
man
la situation dans le dos de basse à
l'est de l'ukraine suscite une vive
préoccupation au kremlin a déclaré
dmitri peskov porte-parole du président
russe selon lui la rhétorique agressive
de kiev ainsi que le nombre croissant
des provocations dans le dôme basse et
laisse augurer du pire je vous propose
d'écouter
[Musique]
la probabilité d'hostilité en ukraine
est toujours élevé c'est toujours un
sujet particulièrement préoccupant pour
nous dans l'ensemble on constate
pourrait-on dire une rhétorique
agressive de la part des autorités
ukrainiennes
on observe l'intensité croissante des
actions provocatrices sur la ligne de
contact nous analysons bien sûr les
déclarations du président zelensky la
déclaration d'hier concernant la russie
s'exprimant au parlement zelensky a
déclaré que récupérer la crimée devrait
être l'objectif principal est la
philosophie de l'ukraine en fait nous
considérons cela comme une menace
directe pour la russie
la situation brûlante annie prennent a
été entre autres discuté par le ministre
russe des affaires étrangères sergueï
lavrov et son homologue américain
anthony blinken à stockholm les deux
chefs de la diplomatie se sont
rencontrés en marge de la réunion
ministérielle de l'osce ce dans la
capitale suédoise ces pourparlers
interviennent sur fond de spéculations
incessantes quant à la possibilité d'une
incursion militaire russe dans le
territoire ukrainien